someone had a question about nutritional
yeast on how you use it in your diet in
your food so I wanted to create a short
video on this topic first of all what is
nutritional yeast it's a type of yeast
which is a microbe which is inactive
it's different than baker's yeast which
is an active yeast so you don't have to
worry about the micro being alive when
you consume it but nutritional yeast has
a lot of nutrition
we've been consuming this for a very
long time it has a complete amino acid
profile it has tons of minerals trace
minerals it has antioxidants like
glutathione which is one of the most
powerful liver antioxidant and also
another powerful antioxidant Celino
methionine this is a selenium which is a
trace mineral enzyme which actually
really helps your immune system but
let's not forget the B vitamins and this
is one of the biggest reasons why I
recommend taking a nutritional yeast but
one of the problems consuming B vitamins
is that the grains are a really good
source of B vitamins okay
but we don't want to consume grains if
you're on the ketogenic plant so what do
we consume nutritional yeast it has
almost all the B vitamins naturally so
it doesn't have b12 because b12 is made
by a bacteria but yeast actually can
make B vitamins and also realized that a
lot of the nutritional yeast products
out there are enriched with synthetic B
vitamins and I don't recommend taking
them it's also they enriched it with a
type of iron that you don't want to
consume you want to get unfortified
nutritional yeast now the product that I
have is non fortified it doesn't have
any synthetic vitamins and this is one
of the reasons why I put a label that
you need a higher dosage because I don't
have the synthetic version which would
give you a lot more B vitamins but those
extra B vitamins are synthetic we want
the natural vitamins that are made from
nutritional yeast now the taste of
nutrition we used is kind of a slightly
cheesy like flavor it's kind of nutty so
some people like it and some people
don't like it but I always just tell
them it's an acquired
tastehh you just have to get used to it
now the nutritional yeast is different
than the yeast extract that you see in
the back of a label and I put a link
down below of a video that I did on MSG
and glutamate so you can kind of learn
more about that because they use yeast
extracts and a lot of food products it's
used as a food additive and also food
flavoring and it has glutamate which is
amino acid but I don't want to get into
that because I have a whole video on
that topic what I do want to show you is
this there are types of yeast extracts
have been around for over a hundred
years as different products and this is
just a few of them they have a lot more
around use around the world
Vegemite ok Australian food spread and
it was created from leftovers from
brewers yeast extract from making beer
and they put it in a spread and it does
have quite a few B vitamins I think now
they do add synthetic B vitamins I'm not
sure if they used them in the past or
not and then you have Marmite which is a
very popular food spread either you love
it or you hate it but it was given to
the British troops in World War 1
because they did have a problem with
berry berry which is a vitamin b1
deficiency and of course this was also
created from the leftover Brewers used
for making beer and so they found they
it works out great to give you B
vitamins and then they had another
product in the 30s called tasty yeast
which is yeast in chocolate of course it
had sugar in there but a lot of people
were taking this back in the thirties
anyway I wanted just to give you the
difference between the different types
of yeast the one that you want to
consume would be nutritional yeast now
you could also use brewers yeast itself
it has a similar profile of B vitamins
the problem is it doesn't taste the same
nutritional yeast is a much better taste
thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos